[Music]
you can go on for days and I love the
stranger thanks theme song yes stranger
things is back you guys and it's about
to get even stranger
of course now Netflix drop the first
trailer for the highly anticipated third
season of the hit series and while it
looks like everything is all fun and the
Sun danger is still lurking around every
corner we're not kids anymore
I mean what did you think
we're just gonna sit my basement all day
play games for the rest of our lives
here's what we know about season three
and what's happening with our friends in
Hawkins Indiana we see Nancy and
Jonathan hanging out of the office at
the Hawkins newspaper then the group
hangs at the pool I mean this is all
about summer totally 11:00 and Max have
some girl time at the new star Court
mall and will is seen crying over an old
pic of the group I feel yeah I feel like
we all don't want to grow up and it's
this is happening now on Stranger thing
yes now there's a fair it looks like so
much fun and a new mayor played by Cary
Elwes and Joyce play by Winona Ryder
seriously looks like she's going through
it I want you to feel like this can
still be your home one thing that hasn't
seen the change is the friendship
between Steve and Dustin they're really
funny at the end of the trailer so
humorous in light of all the darkness
uh-huh and even if Steve does seem to
have a new pal and his coworker Robin
who is played by newcomer Maya Hawk who
also happens to be Ethan Hawke and uma
thurman's daughter how many children are
you friends with this trailer is giving
me that stranger things realness the
mullets the perms the T next the Eggos
the fashion the monsters the aerobic
class this trailer has me living it
makes me want to go Jazzercise one thing
I was not a fan of it looks like 11 is
drowning what's happening there I can't
wait to see that and I love that they
tease that one summer can change
everything
it's so true like we said people grow up
so fast you know what I'm loving most
about it is the WHO blasting in the
background I'm here for it
Netflix also dropped the first images
from season three and it's everything
you could ever want and more spot-on
throwback now I know you're probably
super excited and ready to binge season
three but sadly you're gonna have to
wait until the summer the new season
doesn't drop until the fourth of July
which is a long wait after season two
which came out around Halloween 27 they
do this to us every time but now it gets
always worth the way it is now according
to Sadie's sake season three is like I
said where's the way she teased this to
us in September
what can you tease for us what do you
know if anything I mean I can only say
it's already been out which is that it's
summer for those of you who don't know
so it's summer in Hawkins
kids are out of school it's a little bit
different we've got the pool we've got a
mall now it's gonna be good it's my
favorite season so far how would you
compare it to the first two seasons
differences I feel like each year it
just kind of gets darker and scarier and
season three is definitely the scariest
and darkest and I cannot wait are you
excited I'm very excited but I have a
lot of questions because I know we've
had the demagogue game before now we
have a new threat in town and it looks
pretty scary yeah of course we're gonna
keep you up-to-date with all things
stranger things so make sure you keep
coming back to et until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens and I'm Courtney teza
know
[Music]